culture trafficking illegal excavations
and the antiquities trade in the
interview the president of the Prussian
Cultural Heritage Foundation Haman part
singer mr. part singer
why should museums today be extremely
careful when dealing with ancient
antiquities one davison does should we
know that illegal excavations and grave
robbing are an enormous worldwide
problem not just in countries that are
in turmoil but even in Germany where
there continues to be an illegal trade
in antiquities it's worth billions in
trade each year that's why I believe the
question of provenance of legal
provenance and the legal trade in
antiquities is of central importance for
museums criminologists always talk about
the trade in illegal antiquities in the
same breath as the weapons and illegal
drug trades are there estimates as to
how big the global trade in illegal
antiquities is it's true that they're
often linked together I don't know if
that's absolutely the case but the fact
is that it is an international trade
it's not a question of whether the trade
is worth 1 million 1 billion or 3
billion a year but the addiction to
profit is a real threat to humanity's
cultural heritage and we have to rein it
in you're an archeologist yourself
you've worked in Turkey Russia and
Central Asia did you come in contact
with grave robbers there it's been
finding I did come into contact with the
damage the grave robbers caused you find
robbed graves in almost all of those
countries you see that especially when
the burial site is above ground as a
grave mound or if it's covered by rocks
you know where to look in those cases
you see that frequently and sometimes
you come up against the grave robbers as
I did in northern Pakistan it was there
that I ended up looking down the barrel
of a Kalashnikov we came by chance upon
grave robbers and we surprised them as
they were robbing a stupa a holy
Buddhist structure that contained relics
which they were removing
good funding Taliban it's known that the
Taliban partly financed their operations
in Afghanistan by grave robbing the same
is true of al Qaeda in Iraq what role do
stolen antiquities play today in
financing international terrorism and in
Islamist terrorism we know that members
of is of Islamic state have engaged in
grave robbing and that they have sold
antiquities illegally I can't say how
big a source of income that is however
but it remains a fact that the damage to
cultural heritage is immeasurable that
doesn't just apply to cultural artifacts
that have been removed through illegal
excavations and sold it also applies to
the case of the Buddha statues of
Bamiyan or the mosque in Mosul that was
destroyed by Islamic state just a few
weeks ago or the Islamist group in
Timbuktu in Mali who a few months ago
destroyed holy Islamic graves we're
seeing the loss and destruction of
Islamic culture being pursued with total
zeal and that is something that is
simply unspeakable what does that look
like in reality mrs. Kuan ayahs group in
Syria discovers something how do they
get those artifacts onto the market no
indeed it's relatively simple to remove
objects from the ground in Syria or in
Iraq they identify places of antiquity
they can identify mud brick structures
that have deformed over the ages you
don't need the eye of an archaeologist
to do that those places are relatively
well known and there's also plenty of
literature available as well as tourist
guide books they simply take a bulldozer
or metal detector and they try to find
evidence of important archaeological
items then they tear them from the
ground they deal in objects that the
grave robbers can quickly turn into as
much money as possible works of art clay
tablets and similar items they're less
interested in textiles which are
extremely important to archaeologists
then those objects end up in illegal
channels that have international
connects
the question is who's making the largest
amount of money at which point the
international trade in illegal
antiquities has meeting points around
the world no matter where antiquities
come from whether it's Syria Latin
America Africa or from Germany they're
being traded internationally what's the
best way for the authorities to combat
the international network of dealers
Sinise mom is naturally designed for
first of all it's mainly a problem of
crisis countries where the state
structures and authorities have to be
reestablished there needs to be an
infrastructure and the public needs to
be made aware of what's happening when
villagers who live near a place of
antiquity see grave robbers they must be
made aware that they're destroying our
past our history and they have to take
action by informing the police at the
very least if they see that happening
that applies to people in Germany as
much as it does to people in Iraq the
second thing we need are effective laws
in the countries where we know that
there is illegal trade in antiquities
that's why the reform of Germany's
cultural treasure law which politicians
are planning is of such immense
importance that will limit Germany as a
focal point for the illegal trade let's
talk about Germany a little more for a
moment
almost every court case involving
illegal trade in antiquities has been
dropped why is that the case why is it
that the illegal trade in antiquities is
treated as a minor offence how do you
explain that yes it's true that that is
a widely held belief but things are
changing when it comes to the public's
perception such as when someone visits
Turkey as a tourist or any other country
and they're offered antiques to buy as
souvenirs people need to be clear that
that is not only illegal but by buying
antiquities they're encouraging the
destruction of cultural heritage the
United Nations and UNESCO have an
organization dedicated to protecting
cultural artifacts how are they dealing
with the problem of stolen antiquities
and the trade in illegal goods
Guinan t1 t1 s competition for union
many years ago in 1970 UNESCO agreed a
convention that is extremely important
for this subject it's aimed at limiting
the illegal trade in stolen antiquities
but that convention can only be
effective when it's integrated into
national law Germany did that in 2008
however according to the law cultural
artifacts are only protected when
they're specifically listed that has
made legal disputes very complicated we
have to acknowledge two things at this
point first not every museum in the
world has a full list of cultural
artifacts and has published it
internationally that's one point the
main area of concern is illegal
excavation objects that are still in the
ground and which thieves remove from the
earth those things cannot be listed
that's a crucial issue the reform of the
law dictates that you have to have an
official document proving an artifacts
origin you also need to have an official
document approving export from the
country of origin and not just from a
third country there's a proposal that
could have very big consequences the
suggestion is to ban the global trade in
antiquities completely that would solve
the problem in one swoop because the
markers would dry off what do you think
of that yes that would be a radical
solution but there is trade in
antiquities which is legal there are
many objects that have been in
collections since the 17th 18th and 19th
centuries why should they not be traded
further I don't think there's a problem
with that I think the simplest thing to
do is to adapt the relevant laws so that
they can be effective and that they're
put into practice in reality there's
another point where laws don't help at
all the police and customs authorities
need to be able to recognize the illegal
antiquities recently we published in
Germany the red list of objects from
Syria drawn up by the International
Council of museums that list has
categories and groups of antiquities
that are characteristic for cultures
that existed in Syrian territory
if such objects turn out then the
authorities the customs authorities will
immediately be able to recognize that
they could have their origins in Syria
and then they can take action you've
mentioned collections in western museums
every so often there is quite passionate
debate about returning certain historic
objects to their country of origin here
in Berlin the Nefertiti bust which Egypt
has made repeated claims on is often
mentioned Germany says that claim is not
legitimate can you briefly explain the
situation as it stands now it's
important to say immediately that the
Egyptian government has never made an
official demand for the return of the
Nefertiti bust those claims were made by
individuals by former representatives of
the antiquities authorities or by the
media but there's no official request
for the return because it's known that
at the time there was a law defining how
antiquities were to be shared out when a
foreign archaeological team carried out
a dig with the permission of the
Egyptians the discovered artifacts would
be divided up as compensation for the
expenses the team had paid out the same
was true in Turkey that system applied
to the finding of Nefertiti at the time
the Egyptian authorities had to receive
a complete list and photographs of the
most important pieces before dividing up
the find the fairy tale that the
Nefertiti bust was in a box covered with
clay and that the Egyptians knew nothing
about it is completely false at the time
the Egyptians were more interested in
another artifact in the find we have to
recognize that the hype surrounding
Nefertiti only came later in short the
important thing is whether these objects
were legally claimed at the time of the
find that's the guiding concept for us
every museum needs to be ready to
discuss returning an object to its
rightful owners if in the course of
researching its provenance it's found
that it was illegally obtained that
applies not only to antiquity stolen by
the Nazis but to all cultural artifacts
z32 you can--this begin right at the
very beginning you mentioned stolen
artifacts in Germany grave robbing and
its associated commercial aspect is
something that had
more often in the near and Middle East
in Germany it's about treasure hunters
with metal detectors how much damage are
they causing director Norman charred
nitrogen of course they're causing
enormous damage just imagine that the
most important archaeological find of
Europe's prehistoric era the bronze
Nebra sky disk was found illegally a few
years ago the disk is the oldest known
representation of the cosmos it's an
astonishing work of abstraction it was
here in what is now Germany that our
ancestors turned the observation of the
heavens into a two-dimensional object
long before the ancient Egyptians that's
amazing if that object had disappeared
down an illegal Channel we wouldn't know
anything about it today in decent
Canadian for soybean it's the for my
part senior president of the Prussian
cultural heritage foundation thank you
for giving you insights to Deutsche
Welle